okay
the most absurd question i'm very sorry
very excited but then again i'm not
what what what's the meaning of it all
you you study
history of human history
have you been able to make sense of why
the hell we're here on this
spinning rock does any of it even make
sense what's the meaning
of life what i look at
sometimes that i find interesting is
certain consistencies that we have over
time
uh history doesn't repeat but it has a a
constant and the constant is us
now we change i mentioned earlier the
the
wickedly weird time we live in with what
social media is doing to us as guinea
pigs and that's a new element
but we're still people who are motivated
by
love hate greed envy sex i mean all
these things that would have connected
us with the ancients right
that's the part that always makes
history sound like it rhymes
you know um and when you put the
constant the human element
and you mix it with systems that are
similar so one of the reasons that the
ancient roman republic is something that
people
point to all the time um as a as
something that seems like we're
repeating history is because you have
the two con you have
humans just like you had then and you
have a system that resembles
the one we have here so you throw the
constant in with a system that is
somewhat similar
and you begin to see things that look
like they rhyme a little
um so for me i'm always trying to figure
out more about
us and when you show us in uh
500 years ago in asia and 800 years ago
in africa and you look at all these
different
places that you put the guinea pig in
and you watch how the guinea pig
responds to the different stimuli
and challenges i feel like it helps me
flesh out a little bit more who we are
in the long
timeline not who we are today
specifically but who we've always been
um it's a personal quest it's not meant
to educate anybody else it's
it's something that fascinates me do you
think there's uh
in that common humanity throughout
history of the guinea pig
is there a why underneath it all or is
it somehow like it feels like it's an
experiment of some sort
oh now you're into elon musk and i
talked about this the simulation thing
right nick bostrom's sure
yeah the idea that there's some some kid
and we're the equivalent of an alien's
ant farm you know
and we hope he doesn't throw a tarantula
in just to see what happens
um i think the whys
elude us and i think that what makes
philosophy
and religion and those sorts of things
so interesting is that
they grapple with the whys um
but i'm not wise enough to to
uh propose a theory myself but i'm
interested enough to read all the other
ones out there
so um i let's put it this way i don't
think there's any definitive
why that's been agreed upon but the
various theories are fascinating
yeah whatever it is whoever the kid is
that created this thing
the the ant farm
kind of interesting it's so far a little
bit
a little bit twisted and perverted and
sadistic that's what makes it fun i
think
um but then again that's the russian
perspective i was just gonna say
it is the russian perspective
a little bit what makes the russians so
russian history one day i'll do some
russian history i took it to college
that's the ant farm baby that's an ant
farm with a very very frustrated young
uh uh teenage alien kid
dan i can't say i've already
complimented you way too much
i'm a huge fan this has been an
incredible conversation it's a huge gift
i your your gift of humanity i hope you
let me cut you off and just say you've
done a wonderful job this has been fun
for me
the questions and more importantly the
questions can come from anybody
the counter statements your responses
have been wonderful you made this a very
fun
intellectual discussion for me thank you
well let me have the last word and say i
agree with elon
and despite the doom caster
say that i think we've concluded
definitively and you don't get a chance
to respond that
love is in fact the answer
and the way forward so thanks so much
dan thank you for having me
you